unsere reporter die sind im einsatz für
sie auch in der luft und dort haben sie
diese bilder gemacht bilder über die ab
jetzt ganz deutschland sprechen wird ein
hakenkreuz in einfeld gemäht ein nazi
skandal im brandenburgischen ganz genau
in niederfinow 60 kilometer von berlin
entfernt dort also ein hakenkreuz in
einfeld gemäht aufgefallen ist das schön
an drückte unsere militärexperten den
kennen sie aus unserem bild lagezentrum
zum ukraine krieg und er ist auch pilot
und er ist heute über dieses feld
geflogen und hat damit diesen skandal
aufgedeckt ein hakenkreuz in einfeld
gemüt
jan für uns vor ort ist jetzt peter hell
in niederfinow aus der luft ist das
widerliche nazi symbol gut zu erkennen
peter hast du das feld schon gefunden
wir stehen direkt auf diesem feld
beschränken mal rüber hier das ist eine
fiese da sieht man wie hier gemäht
worden ist direkt an einem kornfeld
allerdings ist so sieht es aus das
hakenkreuz zeichen jetzt vermutlich aus
der luft nicht mehr zu erkennen weil man
sieht es ist quasi ein viereck gemäht
worden vermutlich dann auch nachträglich
und man sieht dass das korn schon hoch
steht dh
das ist eine ganze weile her das ist
eine wiese und
wir waren vorhin auch hier in
niederfinow es ist natürlich noch sehr
früh die einwohner hier die 609
einwohner von diesem kleinen örtchen
hier in brand wo ich die schlafen
natürlich alle noch wir haben aber mit
einem nachbar gerade vor wenigen minuten
sprechen können am gartenzaun und er
sagte dass gestern abend eben auch schon
die polizei hier gewesen sei ein
streifenwagen und eben auch ein
helikopter ist über diese landschaft
geflogen sie haben
luftbildaufnahmen gemacht und das ist
natürlich für die beweissicherung sehr
wichtig denn das ist ja kein
dummer-jungen-streich was hier
stattgefunden haben soll denn ein
hakenkreuz reinzugehen in ein feld das
ist schon strafrechtlich belangbar das
ist § 86a nämlich das zeigen von
symbolen von verfassungswidrigen
organisationen das zum beispiel mit
theoretisch mit drei jahren haftstrafe
bestraft werden kann und hier im dorf
rätselt man natürlich wer das hier
gemacht haben soll und das ist eben die
große frage der wir natürlich auch heute
nachgehen wollen
was könnte da jetzt weiter passiert
werden ein polizeilicher ermittlungen
eingeleitet und es ist noch früh das
dorf das schläft noch ein bisschen aber
gibt es schon irgend ein gespräch
darüber wer das gemacht haben könnte
ja wir haben mit dem nachbarn gesprochen
hier ist man natürlich fassungsloser
also zumindest diese eine nachbar der
weiß gar nichts mehr sagt hier ist ein
ganz normales darauf als er kann sich
gar nicht vorstellen warum und wieso so
was gemacht werden kann
tatsache ist es ist gemacht worden das
heißt ja auch die luftbildaufnahme und
da werden natürlich das trägt natürlich
und zieht natürlich auch ermittlungen
vom staat hinterher das heißt wir gehen
davon aus dass die polizei heute auch im
dorf weitere fragen stellen wird und wie
ich gerade erwähnt aber es ist eine
straftat ein dummer jungen streich so
kann man das nicht mehr nennen
eigentlich und wir sind mal gespannt wir
werden nachher mal in das dorf reingehen
wie man hier zu dieser
aktion steht da muss man ja auch einen
großen trecker haben wir sehen das ja
das ist ja ganz ordentlich aus gemäht
worden da hat man sich was gedacht also
per zufall kann sowas mit einem trecker
von einem landwirt oder von einem
bauern er eben nicht stattfinden also
das hat schon einen hintergrund und das
ist eben nicht mehr witzig so wie ihr es
auch gerade an moderiert hat das ist
eben auch eine straftat und wie denkt
man dass die polizei da auch jetzt
schnell genug ermitteln wird peter
helfen herzlichen dank dir für deine
informationen